c'est la rentrée scolaire la plus
normale depuis deux ans les élèves
voient des sourires peuvent se tenir par
la main l'école en ligne et les masquer
leur forme le déjà loin qui moins
stressant
c'est toujours excitant avec natal afin
de l'avoir ça prend la journée
[Musique]
mais le manque d'enseignants et de
professionnels de succès assombri la
première journée le matin de la rentrée
400 postes à temps plein et à temps
partiel sont toujours vacants à montréal
disons tout pédagogue seront
temporairement relocalisée il plus
d'enseignants non légalement qualifiés
sont embauchés du monde minimalement un
adulte devant devant la classe
flatulences au sein de la banque deux
suppléants pour pour s'assurer que bon
service n'est pas part aux élèves
depuis plusieurs années les enseignants
non légalement qualifiés sont une
solution à la pénurie ils doivent au
moins avoir un baccalauréat
or avec la gravité de la situation à la
rentrée le centre de service scolaire de
montréal doit même faire appel à des
moniteurs de caen pour des besoins
ponctuels
l'alliance des professeurs de montréal
sonne l'alarmé on est en mode solution
pour éteindre le feu donc on cherche à
la dernière minute comme à combler les
trous les défis de rétention dans les
écoles de montréal sont pires
qu'ailleurs ajoute-t-elle
la pénurie enseignante en gros c'est
vicieux à montréal sont ces messieurs
qui dure depuis longtemps et qui
malheureusement risque de durer encore
même s'ils ont réussi à apaiser la
pénurie ailleurs au québec
près de 600 postes de personnels
enseignants à temps plein et sont à
pourvoir dans les écoles du québec ou de
montréal
charles du boullay radio canada montréal